[Emy] Mentalise moi
[Fabien] Salut à vous peuple des internet.
Une toute petite annonce très rapide avant de commencer cette vidéo
j'ai fait le spectacle de création du nouveau spectacle mental roadage
pendant 100 dates en province
et vous avez été nombreux à me demander pourquoi n'y avait pas ne serait-ce qu'une seule
date à paris, bah écoutez bah moi je vais vous le dire, c'est parce que j'avais pas prévu. Mais à la demande générale
et comme j'ai aussi besoin de faire des images pour le nouveau spectacle je fais une date exceptionnelle à Paris le 29 octobre
c'est un petit dimanche des familles et c'est à 19 heures, je vous mets le lien dans la description c'est une petite salle parisienne on prendra le
temps de se rencontrer à la fin mais comme c'est petit ça va vite partir donc si tu es à Paris le 29 octobre et que tu veux
voir ce nouveau spectacle et que tu veux qu'on se doit après c'est maintenant ou jamais en fait voilà c'est tout et maintenant j'ai le
plaisir le kiff
d'être avec Emy Ltr on s'était parlé plusieurs fois etc on avait fait des événements ensemble et on s'est fait une petite vidéo des
familles qui va suivre
je la remercie mille fois d'être ici, j'ai essayé de la mentaliser est ce que ça va bien se passer ou pas
vous allez voir mais c'est drôle.
- Tu sais  que Lie To Me c'est la meilleure série de mentalisme.
- t'es entrain de me dire que la série  The Mentaliste c'est un menteur
- exactement
[Prenant accent allemand] - oh non
- pourquoi tu prends l'accent allemand
- je me sens trahie
Parce que j'ai des origines allemandes et parfois je fais des rechutes
- The mentalist c'est le fantasme de base quoi c'est vraiment le mec qui te regarde et dit tout et il a toujours tout juste.
dans la réalité
tiens là on va faire un truc,
mes mains commencent à transpirer puisque je ne sais pas si je vais réussir
- c'est assez horrible parce que j'espère vraiment que tu vas te planter
j'ai envie de dire "put**n j'ai ni**é un mentaliste
- à chaque fois tout le monde me dit ça je suis dégoûté
- tu sais ce sera un peu une fierté personnelle de dire ah put**n je l'ai niq*é quoi.
non mais moi je suis faible je suis super expressive
- je suis faible c'est bon vas-y mec je suis faible
- non mais je suis super expressive du coup c'est très facile de savoir je suis un livre ouvert c'est affreux
-moi je me suis dit ce qu'on peut faire
c'est deviner ton code de carte bleue
mais si je donne ton code de carte bleue c'est moisie quand même tu vois
- ouais
on pourrait faire en sorte soit que tu prennes les quatre derniers chiffres de ta carte bleue par exemple
- je les connais pas
- invente un code à quatre chiffres
mais on dit que c'est ton code de carte bleue pour aujourd'hui
-d'accord ok
- et ce sera dans le titre et là vous vous rendrez
que c'est pas son vrai code à partir de maintenant mais tu as cliquer c'est beaucoup trop tard
- et oui le putaclic paye
alors allez voir la dernière vidéo d'Emy peut-être que c'est pas la dernière mais je vous mettrais une vidéo en lien
dans la description allez voir
- peut-être que ce n'est pas la dernière parce qu'on ne sait pas quand on va la publier  cette vidéo
-mais oui c'est vrai on la publie quand
- écoutes , moi je suis assez dispo
-et puis je fais pas des vidéo d'avance donc
- si mais t’inquiète je me placerais.
c'est n'importe quoi faut que je me calme
c'est l'Australie
- ça ne veut rien dire les excuses les plus moisies du monde, c'est l'Australie c'est pour ça
- il parle  #Hello
pardon j’arrête, j'avais dit que je serais calme, je suis calme
- moi de toute manière je mets pas de montage je laisserai tout
- très bien moi ça me va, tu sais moi j'ai pas de problème
avec moi tu sais y'a pas de soucis et l'accent revient c'est fou
- et en plus il étais demi allemand demi suisse c’était très étrange
- parfois j'arrive même à insérer le belge en plus
mentalise moi on a dit
- alors on t'invente un code de carte bleue
dira-t-on ce sera ton code de carte bleue pour aujourd'hui il peut être inspiré de faits réels c'est à dire de
ça peut être ta date de naissance ça peut être  des trucs comme ça
mais je te le déconseille le mieux c'est de prendre un truc complètement random
mais il va falloir que tu t'en souviennes. Donc tu inventes un code à quatre chiffres dans ta tête
tu me dis quand c'est bon et quand tu penses que tu es capable de le retenir
-c'est bon
-C'est bon ok je suis allé chercher ça et je me suis dit que pour trouver donc quand on allait utiliser les micro mouvements musculaires
- oui je t'ai dis tant que je n'ai pas de courbatures musculaire ça me va
- Donc on va commencer par des squats
alors sur ce petit bloc notes comme vous pouvez le constater j'ai écrit un deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit neuf zéro
tu va me prendre le poignet un peu comme si tu me prenais le pouls et tu mets deux doigts en dessous et deux doigts au dessus comme ça
ok d'accord tu cherches pas guidé ma main quand je passe
mon doigt par exemple si là je fais rien voir si je le passe sur un de tes chiffres à toi
tu te dis dans ta tête celui-là en fait partie
- ah oui d'accord ok
-oui un truc positif
il se passe rien du tout dans cette vidéo
Soit elle a des chiffres qui sont dans les extrêmes et du coup je vais les mélanger et pour voir ce qui se passe
- il se passe que je suis surdouée
donc je suis moi-même mentaliste que je n'en ai pas parlé
- ou alors que tu ne pense pas
tout est possible.
-et que je j'ai pas d'âme
et comme ça on va passer ça comme ça je regarde même temps
-je regarde moi, je regarde bien
- oui bah oui
- c'est un peu con sinon
- ça n'a aucun sens
- j'ai assez de pression?
- ouais ça va
je vais Bouger le bloc notes en même temps que ma main
Pour l'instant je vous le dis  je vois pas ce que je fais mais par contre comme ça ça me permet de
-t'es dans le néant là
- je n'ai pas de réaction aux bons endroits
Ok alors par contre ça fait plusieurs fois que toi
inconsciemment mais c'est normal tu m'emmènes vers là du coup je vais entourer mon un
et ce petit rire agacé
m'indique  qu'il y'a du un quelque part ok allez je vais essayer d'en avoir un autre
- oh je suis si faible
- je mise sur les deux
- peut-être que je t'induit en erreur
-en fait si il n'y avait pas de deux il y aurait eu de la joie sur ton visage en mode je t'ai trop eu
- t'es vraiment le genre de personnage avec qui on a vraiment pas envie de passer la soirée
le mec qui sait exactement ce que tu pense
- ah d'accord
d'accord
continuons
est ce que tu peux répondre à une question dans ta tête?
- ouais
-est-ce que un ou plusieurs chiffres sont doublés?
oui merci
-quoi
Ok donc j'ai du neuf du 2 du 1
-il me fait peur ce type , il me fait peur
- neuf, deux, un
- c'est lui Voldemort
- je suis content déjà d'avoir le contenu
j'ai le contenu
- si tu l'as
- arrête je l'ai déjà c'est sur que je l'ai
merde tu me fais douter un peu quand même
Olala c'est terrible
je suis beaucoup trop influençable moi même on peut me donner le doute
-c'est horrible
-non non mais je vais partir
là tu vas répondre pour de vrai  de manière verbale consciente  et tout
est-ce que cet ensemble de chiffres a du sens pour toi ou pas?
- non
- non c'est complètement random
- ouais
- ok ça marche, mais mais vous avez bien fait
puisque c'est le thème de cette video
c'est le thème de cette vidéo
- je contamine tout le monde
- je me rends compte que c'est quand je galère à trouver la suite que j'utilise l'accent pour comprendre
- ta prochaine vidéo tu feras ça tu te diras à puta*n c'est Emy
-tu vas penser qu'a ton premier chiffre et tu va me dire
9-2-1  9-2-1 comme ça en boucle jusqu'à temps que je t'arrête
- 9-2-1 9-2-1 ....
- stop
Vous pouvez repasser ce petit passage
en boucle vous aussi pour deux raisons la première c'est que ça va augmenter mon watch time et ça c'est cool
- cet escroc
- Et la deuxième raison c'est que vous allez entendre la manière dont elle  dit 9-2-1 9-2-1
en fait tu as fait exactement 9-2-UN 9-2-UN
- c'est parce que c'est l’Allemagne
- c'est l’Allemagne akhf
- je me suis trahi
- mais moi je pense que c'est  surtout du pléonasme
de penser c'est à dire que quand tu penses à quelque chose et que tu le dis tu le mets en valeur
c'est parti mais pour le deuxieme donc tu mets deuxième chiffre
un petit peu en fond en mode de pensée puis tu fais 9-2-1 9-2-1
- 9-2-1 9-2-1 9-2-1 ....
- ok c'est cool, on le fait pour le troisième , tu mets le troisième dans le fond de ta tête et c'est parti
- 9-2-1 9-2-1 ....
-Ok j'hésite entre deux donc je vais les mettre comme ça et le dernier
- vous qui  regardez cette vidéo vous allez rire à cet moment là
9-2-1 9-2-1 9-2-1 ...
- pourquoi ils vont rire à ce moment là ?
- 9-2-1 9-2-1 9-2-1 ...
ça me fait rire ça me fait rire c'est bête ça me fait rire
- tu sais une angoisse maximale monte à l'intérieur de moi de en fait j'ai pas du tout les bons chiffres
et elle se dit et là quand il va  retourner vous allez bien vous fout*e de sa gueule
oh putain je suis trop stressé
Ok bon je pense en tout cas avoir le dernier  mais j'ai un
gros doute sur le troisième donc le seul code qui compte  c'est pas les notes que j'ai pris
c'est celui que j'ai encadré
Emy Ltr
- oui
-symbolisant ton nom de familles par trois consonnes
est-ce que s'il vous plaît sans vouloir trop vous commandez
vous pourriez avoir l'obligeance sansntourner autour du pot et sans essayer de passer par quatre chemin parce que je suis complètement sûr de moi
- oui ça ce voit
- est ce que vous pourriez me donnez votre code de carte bleue en quatre chiffres s'il vous plaît
-12 13
- 12 13 oh puta*n
le neuf n'a jamais été présent
-c'est pour ça quand tu m'a dis pour le dernier je me suis dis bah le pauvre c'est horrible
-putain tu étais pas
- par contre je suis pas mal c'est à dire que que mon neuf ce qui est un trois bons écoute
je considère avoir réussi à donc
75 %
-bah ouais là déjà je suis surprise que tu es réussi à trouver ça c'est dingue
et est ce que dans une enveloppe j'avais pas marqué qu'en fait je ferai une erreur exprès au dernier coup
ça aurais été trop bien
- mon regard m'a trahi j’étais là
oh Non il est trop chaud ouais
mais ouais franchement pas mal
C'est hallucinant
juste en tenant ton poignet et juste en écoutant ce que je dis c'est quand même incroyable
en tout cas tu as bien caché que j'étais en train de me tromper pour le neuf parce que je n'ai pas vu du tout
ou non en fait c'est toi c'est toi qui m'a aidé à cacher en fait parce que comme tu m'as dit des choix au début
- ouais je t'ai donné des clefs au fur et à mesure
- voilà je savais qu'en faisant ça
- moi je suis un gros blaireau je sais pas pourquoi je fais ça
- non mais après c’était de la déduction du coup j'ai essayé de t'induire en erreur en faisant des choses que tu m'avais conseillé en faisant l'inverse
- en spectacle je fait la même chose c'est à dire que comme j'adore le mentaliste et j'adore transmettre
j'explique au fur et à mesure comment ça se passe alors que je n'ai pas fini mon coup de bluff on va dire que
je devrais soit apprendre à fermer ma bouche soit assumer de me tromper,
j'assume de me tromper voilà c'est pas très grave,
merci Emy
- ah bah merci à toi je suis très très contente
- et merci d’être venu sur la chaîne c'est cool
- oh oui et puis on en fait une sur la mienne aussi parce que on fait une collaboration
ça veut dire qu'il va peut être trouver mon vrai code de carte bleue
- est-ce que tu veux dire qu'on collabore
Je ne cautionne pas cette vidéo
- du coup je ne sais pas comment finir cette vidéo
bah si toi aussi tu es gêné désabonne toi de la chaîne
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo comme d'habitude vous pouvez liker ou vous abonnez mais surtout vous abonner également à la chaîne d'Emy
- non surtout la tienne
- non c'est la tienne
-non surtout la tienne
- alors c'est moi qui raccroche alors
et je mets un lien dans la description
de deux vidéos d'Emy celle qu'on  va faire ensemble juste après
et celle qu'elle a sorti le jour où nous tournons cette vidéo qui est une vidéo très intéressante
- d'où mon stresse énorme
- d'où stress énorme, si tu veux savoir pourquoi elle est stresser en ce moment et qu'elle va se jeter sur son téléphone dès qu'on aura coupé
va voir cette vidéo elle est très importante et très cool voilà merci à toi
merci à toi, merci à toute l'équipe présente
- merci aux lumière merci au règlement intérieur merci à Sherlock
- merci à l'algorithme merci aux démonétisation merci on vous aime au revoir
- bisou
- alors ça par exemple c'est mon rond à moi
- alors excuse moi c'est pas très poli
parce que j’étais quand même dans la vidéo , tu aurais pu mettre mon rond d'abonnement moi aussi
- je mets ton rond regarde je mets ton rond et je l'entoure c'est magnifique
- peut-être que si j'étais pas venu te dire ça tu aurais pas mis mon rond ça m'enerve c'est pas très cool
- est ce qu'ils savent qu'ils peuvent appuyer dessus même depuis leur téléphone tu crois
- bah je pense enfin j'espère pour eux